demonstrations around the city they're
firing tear gas now and they hit a man
in the chest he's reported to be
bleeding profusely then that would be a
dramatic twin event that turns out that
that was a police bullet and a protester
who's lying injured now sounds like he's
practically injured as well for the last
few hours a number of fires in a number
of areas upon Congress scene water
cannon Binford rubber bullets being
fired at or at least one journalist
injured they cordoned off from early on
this morning the police
[Music]
which sticks to the skin
believed to be filled with pepper spray
which also stings quite a lot on them on
the skin I'm trying to stop this from
going ahead debating regime and they
shut down roads a lot of shots were shot
they closed down the number of the
subway stations
they shut down the number of the subway
stations here where we're going to get
caught in the the protesters treinta the
protesters are throwing petrol bombs as
well as the police they're actually very
keen on international coverage of this
these protests and it's intended here in
Hong Kong with very much seen and have
been very much seen as a day of mourning
not as a day of celebration
with something because it's very toxic
to breathe I think it's not just water
not just blue dye
watching what's going on here
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
explosion of events here fired on them
a protest Minh ended up with that
protester being seriously injured we've
got to get the full effect obviously
things are very very chaotic at the
moment but that as soon as that starts
coming around the protesters I think
that will have a dramatic impact on them
we'll keep you abreast of what's
happening right now the protesters are
trying to get away from the police and
avoid arrest